this morning Prince Harry and Megan
Markel are making their last official
appearance together as senior members of
Britain's royal family the Duke and
Duchess are closing out a busy weekend
with a service at Westminster Abbey in
London they'll mark Commonwealth day
alongside the Queen and then starting
next month they're officially out of a
job and out of the family Mark Phillips
is outside Westminster Abbey mark would
have the royal couple of couple been up
to well good morning it has been
something of a farewell tour for Megan
and Harry here these past few days and
they seem to have decided if you're
going to go out go out in style this was
the way it was supposed to be the
dashing couple all dressed up in royal
red the future of the monarchy in safe
and popular hands they were in London's
Royal Albert Hall for a concert but they
seemed to be the stars of the show
the singing of the anthem god save the
queen' was a statement to they may have
decided the spotlight of royal attention
was too much but the monarchy will go on
without them
[Music]
the couple have hardly been out of the
spotlight as they wind up their royal
duties these last few days they brought
more than glamour to the Windsors and
maybe that was part of the problem some
members of the British establishment had
accepting Megan into their ranks Emily
Nash's royal editor of halal magazine
Megan was also able to attract people
who weren't perhaps traditionally
interested in the royal family there was
a lot more diversity on walkabout when
she was there we saw a lot more young
women particularly young black women who
hadn't perhaps felt a connection to the
royal family previously and that of
course is going to be a loss to the
royal family
maybe that's why Megan chose the school
with the mixed race student body at
which to make a speech about
International Women's Day this weekend
would perhaps predictable results the
couple have one more official royal
engagement here as service at
Westminster Abbey with the rest of the
royal family and it turns out it's
significant for the first time they will
not be included in the royal procession
with the other Royals as the Queen
leaves they'll stay seated with this
family it seems Tony you're either in or
you're out
and they're out thank you very much